Apple's airpods Pro 4 are coming so if
you're thinking about buying a pair of
airpods don't wait watch this video
because I'm going to tell you guys all
of the new features that are coming out
and some are really surprising we're
going to talk about price points release
date and more now I am actually excited
that they're going to be updating the
airpods 3 because I've actually been
using them over the last month or so cuz
I misplaced the pros and I actually like
them in a few ways better than the pros
but there are some features and things
that they are lacking now they have been
out for over 2 years now and when they
did come out I absolutely loved them and
I actually stopped using my airpods Pro
original because the sound quality was
much improved and I really enjoy high
quality sound so that was a nice step up
because it had new processing it had new
drivers uh but of course you did not get
any active noise C cancellation now the
first thing that is going to be improved
is going to be the sound quality because
the crazy thing is Apple release these
USB type-c earpods when Apple launched
the new iPhone 15s and they actually
sound better than airpods 3 and these
only cost
$119 because they actually have updated
drivers built in and of course you are
plugging it in so if you care about
sound quality airpods 4 are going to to
be better now the other thing we know
that's going to be updated is the case
we are going to have USB type-c built in
we got that with the updated case on
airpods Pro 2 and now that the iPhones
have updated it makes sense for them to
swap that out to USB type-c as well now
the information that I'm going to be
sharing is from Mark German from his
poweron newsletter and he is one of the
most accurate leakers so all of this is
legit and I think that the craziest
thing about the new airpods 4 is that
there's going to be two sets of them and
the features that they are going to have
now we still have airpods to the Apple
cells those have been out for a very
long time and we have the airpods 3 so
Markman is saying that they are both
going to be replaced at the same time
and the reason that they're both getting
replaced is because there is some
confusion right now between both of them
being sold that they're too similar now
personally for myself I know there's a
quite a big difference between them and
the airpods 3 introduced some really
nice new features of course we had the
updated Design This one is the airpods
pro that I took to work today with me uh
but we had that different shape built in
we had the controls that are built in
where you actually go ahead and press on
the stem instead of tapping it that's
much better um and with that we actually
had a skin sensor which the pros didn't
have at the time so if you toss them in
a pocket it they won't just turn on and
play automatically they will only play
if you put it into your ear so that is
really nice we had better sweatproof
resistance actually had a microphone
that can hear and tune the sound which
made it really good um and the the call
Quality also was a really nice
Improvement so it was quite a nice
update now the reason that we're going
to get two sets of airpods uh forth
generation is because one is going to
get active noise cancellation just like
like the pros now this is amazing
because I actually wished that the
airpods 3 had it when I was using it now
of course they do not have the ear tips
like the pros do so if they um add that
it's not going to work as well but apple
is going to be changing the shape and
design of it and who knows they could
put a rubber kind of uh you know
surround on it so it seals in better
maybe foam or they could use inear
design for the active noise cancellation
version just make it cheaper uh but if
you look at a lot of comments people do
not want that because it's just not
comfortable for some people the fit
isn't there they don't like the pressure
that your ear canals can get sweaty so
personally I hope that they can give us
somewhat of a hybrid where you don't
have that in ear canal seal but you can
still get some active noise cancellation
that can filter out some frequencies but
what I think is more important is having
transparency mode because airpods Pros
even though they're sealed in with
transparency mode I actually hear my
environment better than with airpods 3
that don't steal in your ear but they
still block out a lot of sound so I
would love the ability to hear my
environment better and with that one
reason they're adding this is because
the FDA actually approved
over-the-counter hearing aids with
devices like these so Apple can actually
tune them up they can actually Market it
as hearing aid devices or to be able to
assist you and then with that they're
going to be having a test that you can
use to be able to adjust that so that is
going to be really cool now we know that
the fit is going to be improved but
we're not sure if it's going to have the
silicone tips like I mentioned I think
Apple might be able to change the design
a little bit to make it fit more ears
better um but we'll see if they add
those ear tips if they do it will only
be on the higher end version now the
lower end version is going to keep a
regular design and it's going to be
without those extra nice features kind
of just a replacement for the airpods 2
just with some nice updates now just
like the airpods Pro 2 the case is going
to be updated to include a speaker and a
microphone built in now this has been
gamechanging to have the ability to find
your airpods when you lose them and it
works just like an air tag where it will
guide you to where it's at it can
actually play a sound and you can find
them and it's one of the best features
that separates it from all the other
thirdparty options now I presume this is
one thing that's not going to come on
the cheaper version but who knows they
might surprise us the airpods 2 are 250
bucks of course you can get them cheaper
we'll leave a link down below the
airpods 3 are 169 without Max safe
charging case and then airpods 2 are 129
now of course the airpods 2 are selling
for 99 bucks right now uh because people
don't really want to buy them they're
discounted quite a bit and so I think
that would be very cool if Apple
actually makes the airpods 4 without
active noise cancellation at $99 because
there's so many headphones out there
we've reviewed a lot of them that are
really good for a really low price but
who knows if they include the speaker
and the tracking it might be still 129
now for the airpods 4 with active noise
cancellation I presume that those are
going to stay at about the same price
point 169 maybe 179 I think that's a
great value for what you are going to
get especially with the integration with
iOS and then airpods Pro 2 are going to
stay the same and those that we still
have to wait over a year maybe year and
a half to get those updated so when are
we going to get these well Mark Gman
says it's in 2024 obviously but maybe
around September when we have new
iPhones launch now airpods 3 actually
launched in October it wasn't at the
iPhone event and airpods 2 those
actually launched in March nowhere near
the iPhone event and if we take a look
at the Amazon listing page for airpods 3
they don't have any you cannot even buy
them not even order them to get shipped
in a month or so it's completely not
there and that is telling me that
there's a really good chance that we
might actually get airpods 4 in Apple's
spring event or maybe at a similar time
when the Vision Pro launches and a lot
of times they'll actually launch these
without an event it'll just show up on
on the website um so we could be getting
these very very soon so you guys let me
know what you think about them do you
want your tips um on them with active
noise cancellation or would you rather
not have that um are you willing to buy
these over a pro if they're going to
cost less and have some of the same
features um uh yeah is it worth updating
or are you going to wait a lot longer to
get airpods Pro 3 which is going to be
maybe mid
2025 I'm personally excited for earpods
are great I use them every single day so
let me know your thoughts go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next
[Music]
video